foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this video I want to show all of you
what George R Martin said about the
Winds of Winter as well as House of the
dragon's second season in his new not a
Blog update he revealed some interesting
information about the writers and actor
strike the status of the show and his
next novel In The Song of Ice and Fire
Saga he let us know how much work has
been done on House of the dragon and he
also let us know how often he's writing
the Winds of Winter now let's have a
look at George R Martin's website
because I would like to discuss what he
had to say he said those of you who have
been following the news out of Hollywood
will already know that sag Astra the
actors Union has gone on strike joining
the writer's Guild of America we have
been striking since May the second if
you're in LA or New York City or
sometimes here in Santa Fe you may have
seen our picket lines those lines have
gotten much bigger since the actors
joined us and you may see some familiar
faces holding signs the SAG contract
ended on June 30th but the actors gave
every chance to reach an equitable
agreement by extending negotiations
unfortunately it was disregarded the
studios did not move an inch and they
still refused to address some of the
most important issues on the table this
includes Ai and payments and residuals
from streaming they gave the actors no
choice but to walk as for the writers
well the studios are not even talking to
us all negotiations were shut down back
in May when the strike began it's hard
to reach any agreement when the other
side won't even come to the table I
joined the wga in 1986 and have been
through several strikes with them we
have made gains in all of them but some
issues are more important than others
and this year's strike is the most
important of my lifetime no one can be
certain where we go from here but I have
a bad feeling that this strike will be
long and bitter it might even get as bad
as the infamous 1985 strike though I
hope not now some of you may be
wondering how this has affected me and
my work one of the very few shows still
shooting his house of the dragon as you
may have read that's true I'm told the
second season is halfway done all of the
scripts had been finished months before
the wga strike began no writing has been
done since to the best of my knowledge
House of the Dragon is shot mostly in
London and a little bit in Wales Spain
and various other locations which is why
filming has continued our actors are
members of the British Union Equity not
sag-aftra and though Equity strongly
supports their American cousins British
law forbids them from staging any
sympathy strike honestly I was shocked
to hear that how in the world could they
allow such anti-labor regulations to be
enacted now as for myself my overall
deal with HBO was suspended on June 1st
I'm assuming this is because George thus
helped them with writing although he
doesn't do a whole lot of writing for
HBO lately I believe he does still help
out in the writer's room for House of
the dragon as well as their new show
about Duncan egg not to mention these
shows are based on his writing so that
may automatically categorize him as one
of their writers even if he's not there
every day either way I wish he would
have given more information about the
suspension now he goes on to say I still
have a lot to do of course in that I am
one of the lucky ones these strikes are
not really about name writers or
producers or showrunners most of whom
are fine we're striking for the
entry-level writers the story editors
the students hoping to break in the
actor who has four lines the guy working
his first staff job who dreams of
creating his own show one day as I did
back in the 1980s last week we had a
great meeting with the producers on the
Iron Throne the stage play we've been
working on over the last few years the
scripts for that one are coming along
well and it's got me very excited
sag-aftra covers television and film but
not the stage so the strike had no
effect there maybe we will even be able
to bring the show to the West End by
well no better not to say do not want to
jinx anything and yes yes of course I've
been working on Winds of Winter almost
every day writing rewriting editing
writing some more making steady progress
not as fast as I would like and
certainly not as fast as you would like
but he is moving forward nonetheless now
as some of you may already know it has
officially been a dozen years since
George R Martin released A Dance with
Dragons he hasn't released a new novel
for his A Song of Ice and Fire Saga
since July of 2011. It's actually kind
of shocking to think he is still writing
the wins of winter in 2023. I'm guessing
he felt the need to give some kind of an
update since it has now been another
year since the release of his last novel
I'm sure the fans have been sending him
a lot of nice messages since we've
reached another anniversary it is one
hell of a milestone to still be writing
the Winds of Winter this many years
later now the good news is he says he's
still writing nearly every day it's also
good to know that house of the Dragon
hasn't been affected by any other
strikes since he says they're about
halfway done with the second season I
hope it means they're still on schedule
for the summer release I know I hate to
have to wait any longer I'm not the only
one who's anxious to see what happens on
the show next now let me know what all
of you think about the new updates down
below also don't forget to subscribe I
will make sure to keep you up to date on
any new information about these new Game
of Thrones shows as well as George RR
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire novels
once again I have to thank all of you
for stopping by and watching another
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]